there was a time in this country that
was changing topics big time when the
idea of mass school shooting was
unthinkable you remember those days
now it seems inevitable that it is going
to happen again something that is
certainly not lost on america's children
meg oliver visited a school in new
jersey and talked to five children ages
10 to 14
about how does it feel to go to school
now and the strict safety measures in
places at their school meg joins us now
from inside one school in little falls
meg good morning to you
gail good morning we came here because
of the extraordinary security measures
the superintendent put in place with the
help of local police we also wanted to
hear from students about the recent rash
of mass shootings and how they feel
about going to school
it's
crazy to know that
when i come into school every day i'm
lucky
that i get to to come home
i think that's
not something that i should be feeling
is i'm glad i was able to come home from
school today that goes through your mind
that you feel lucky to be able to come
home
that um
it's just it's something we have to live
with and it's hard to accept
twelve-year-old michael kawadi is one of
the millions of kids across the country
shaken after the school shooting in
uvalde it could have been our school it
could have been your school
how do you deal with that it's a lot to
take in definitely and i think hearing
about what happened
it's it almost feels surreal i think
school is a place to learn and not a
place to die
and
i'm praying for all of the families i
can't even imagine what it's like
there's really like there's no words for
it it's like those kids could have been
superstars like they could have changed
the world and then they're just gone you
can't bring them back like that's hard
and some of them had passions no child
or anybody going to school should have
to live in a fear of something happening
to them and they're not going to return
home raise your hand if you feel safe
coming to school
all of you why is that adrian
because police police officers walk
around the school
and we do drills
and
we're prepared
at school number one in little falls new
jersey police officers are on patrol
daily police presence is a big deal
especially during these times you know
so we want to make sure that everyone is
ok
three years ago superintendent tracy
marinelli partnered with the police
chief to ramp up security every single
district every administrator
needs to prepare their building as if
their own children
or grandchildren go there
it's sinking in isn't it
how do you get through the day
knowing you have 900 students to protect
some of these are harder than others but
i'm so secure in what we have here i'm
fearful for people that don't go to
school here
every school has a police substation
inside five officers are assigned to
walk through the district's three
schools multiple times a day do you feel
politicians are doing enough to protect
our schools
i feel
that
the things that we're putting into place
are not political they're things that if
you have a proactive administration a
board of education that is supportive
and you know you're fiscally responsible
you could get those things done the best
way for schools to be successful is
really for politics not to intermingle
all right anybody else ready fifth grade
science teacher monica heaney says being
proactive by having security measures in
place isn't taking a political stance
having those certain things in place
don't seem to be so big in political i
don't really understand why
it can't start there one of the students
that we talked to said he feels lucky if
he makes it home after school at night
how does that make you feel knowing that
your students feel lucky to be alive
after going to school for the day so sad
should not be anything that students or
children feel should never be
but this is the world we live in and
unfortunately they see the negative and
then they have to think about that are
you hoping by speaking out that maybe
this will make a difference yeah i hope
so how so justin
because us speaking out about it will
like
um tell other civilians that gun
violence is a horrible thing to do
what do you think jade i really hope it
makes a change in that in like my future
and
i know a while but like my children's
future i hope that they won't have to
live in a world or i would have to live
in fear of them going to school and
being scared
no students should have that fear in
addition to having the police substation
inside the school officers are outside
every day when students arrive and
depart their security cameras are linked
to police headquarters and they changed
every door in the district to make sure
they can lock it from the inside as well
this school is the exception not the
standard and they're hoping more
districts follow suit nate
hearing one of the kids say this should
be a place to learn not a place to die
is absolutely heartbreaking meg thank
you